sur les quarante personnes qui sont
décédées il a trente et une qui était
résidente en martinique il y en a cinq
qui étaient guadeloupéen 2 guyanaise est
un étranger de mémoire ou trois guyanais
c'était hier au cours de la conférence
de presse du préfet on apprenait que
parmi les quarante personnes décédées du
coronavirus au chum depuis le mois de
mars dernier que seules 32 personnes qui
ont contracté la maladie en martinique
sont mortes au chu pierre zobda-quitman
à cause du coc vide
les huit autres personnes sont des
évacuations sanitaires
cinq viennent de la guadeloupe de la
guyane est une personne d'un pays
étranger
un nouveau décès à déplorer en semaine
47 qui amène en tout 1 40 décès survenu
dans le cadre de l'épidémie de koffi 19
en martinique mais je vous rappelle t8
de ces décès sont liés à des évacuations
sanitaires depuis la guyane où depuis
d'un road book en comparaison avec la
guadeloupe 163 personnes sont mortes du
kobudo chu des abymes 145 d'entre elles
sont domiciliés en guadeloupe 18
évacuations sanitaires et sec
ouaddou p1 décédé en martinique au total
153 nous payons personnes résidentes en
guadeloupe sont mortes du coup vite
depuis le mois de mars
comment expliquer ces chiffres outre le
manque de moyens dont disposent de chu
de la guadeloupe
il semblerait que les malades en
martinique soit pris en charge très tôt
par rapport à la première vague
on a amélioré la prise en charge des
personnes les personnes ont tendance à
venir plutôt aussi à l'hôpital être
hospitalisé plutôt pris en charge
plus précocément en réanimation lorsque
les personnes passaient bien on a aussi
modifié un petit peu des techniques qui
font que pour un certain nombre d'entre
eux le séjour en réanimation est plus
court et donc tout ça ça concourt à
moins de 17 avec 32 morts au 26 novembre
2020 le taux de mortalité en martinique
est de 0,0 0 7%
en guadeloupe il est plus élevée 0,01
pour cent et au total pour toute la
france ils de 0,02 pour cent pour
l'instant la martinique est la région
d'outre-mer est l'une des régions de
france où le coronavirus ferait le moins
deux morts lorsqu'on regarde le la
proportion de décès chez les patients
qui sont hospitalisés en réanimation
par exemple en martinique c'était déjà
d'ailleurs le cas à la première vague on
avait un pourcentage de personnes tout à
fait dans la moyenne nationale même
plutôt assez bas par rapport à la
moyenne nationale
rapporté à la population et au nombre de
patients qui ont été diagnostiqués
pendant cette deuxième vague bien
effectivement c'est parmi les meilleurs
taux les meilleurs proportion de
français
et pour ceux qui se demandent pourquoi
le chum on reçoit des malades devenus de
la guadeloupe de la guyane c'est pour
qu'il se fasse soigner en réanimation
avec cette machine lac mots elle permet
l'oxygénation du sang
la martinique est le seul centre
hospitalier à posséder ces machines aux
antilles guyane